hang out with a chick was beautiful like
this was years ago really beautiful and
she was like
and she said something she goes yeah man
it was sick
and I go and I was like oh that's like
the worst thing to do should I introduce
her to me
I got the egg dude
we're on the couch together and she goes
yeah and I go
and my penis goes
laughs
Runk
[Music]
hello hello
hello
[Music]
dude good job man you got a dog on your
lap dude you ever think about how you
have a dog on your lap and it's so close
because he's touching your genitals are
touching basically only there's a sheet
I've straight up never once thought
about me either me neither I brought up
because I was wondering if you thought
of that when she rolls over and I happen
to see it uh all I ever think Billy my
old dog friends of mine will from back
in the day will absolutely know Billy
Billy's the queen Legend pisses me off
that Anthony's in the bathroom flush the
toilet but well nobody don't hear that I
know but I heard it and that's what
matters especially with Billy yeah
um so when she would roll over
especially but Charlie too and I would
see it
uh I would just think well my that's a
that looks like calamari okay because it
looks so much like a calamari and
nothing else yeah probably because it
does no I I don't have problems oh
because you're the one that does because
you think about the other thing that you
said in the beginning right I don't have
problems because all I do is see with my
eyes my eyes make a connection to a
thing that it looks like more than the
thing that it actually is which is
calamari so boringly you broke it down I
love the calamari what's that wait
what's that from wait what's that from
Ray Winston's doing the best acting ever
and sexy beast when he first hears Don
Logan is coming into town and he's just
like
I love the calamari yeah yeah so good I
just did so good too I just did so good
okay
okay yeah Ray Winston is the guy from
pull them up he's the guy from he's the
best no that's the best is Tim Daly
no the best is yeah Ray was is amazing
yeah it's so good yeah but you you
plebeians out there would know him from
The Departed probably plebeians you know
but but but but the best is and I always
forget his name God I always forget his
name and he is legit the best actor
who's like him uh is he gonna say Jason
Isaacs no Tom he's great but Tom
oh Tom Wilkinson yeah he's the greatest
actor yeah he's amazing you know what he
has a small part in but is just so
amazing and I know what you're going to
say too after I say this okay The Ghost
Writer oh uh with Nicholas Cage knew it
uh I knew it nope the Roman place what
superhero is he
Ray Winston is amazing he was in Batman
and he played a broadcast from Brooklyn
uh Ray Winston did no Tom Wilkins no no
I'm sorry Tom Wilkinson yeah yeah yeah
Tom Wilkins is amazing in the Batman
with not dude do you remember that old
really old like OG trans movie that he
was in he he played a guy I believe I
never saw it but I remember the trailer
so well like this isn't like in the
maybe early odds or even late 90s he
played like a normal family man who
comes out as someone who is it I don't
know if he's trans but he's like in the
bedroom or whatever quiet in the bedroom
no that's just a great movie that he's
in oh he's in this is this was an HBO
movie with him and like I think it might
I want to say Jessica Lang but I'm not
sure it was a TV movie back before TV
movies were like before they were the I
think yeah yeah okay cool well
um all right listen guys uh did we make
a big enough deal about Charlie though
no we we did but okay yeah I I might not
like Charlie Charlie's great she's great
Charlie's go to the obviously the thing
so we can talk about the thing we got a
patreon uh up and running now we're
starting to drop episodes
uh in May uh oh May May 21st uh
patreon.com Lifeline luxury
you're doing it so wrong am I doing it
oh God I got it got it okay just cut
that out or or leave it we don't care
um uh June is when it starts right
this episode comes out hi it's May 21st
and patreon.com Lifeline luxury the
patreon episodes drop
starting June 4th
um so you can go to uh patreon get
signed up we do at least two a month uh
episodes that are at least 30 minutes
long of Matt and I just bantering
because I know that that's what a lot of
the fans want uh no videos no calls or
anything like that so it's just us
Brotherly Love Lifeline luxury
patreon.com luxury and uh so sign up
today uh I'm on tour chrisley.com go to
hit them cities uh and then we can go uh
Matt you got what I got my own solo
one-on-one I'm helping people out in the
world man they reach out to me they say
hey Matt I need you I beg of you help me
and I say
that's not a problem because I got help
tons of help to give Tons of love to
give
frankly uh you can make your own
appointment with me at mattdelia.com
or you can leave us a message on the
hotline
213-973-8095 or uh send in a video if
you have a question watch lifeline.com
and merch lifelinemirch.com whatever we
got it going you know what I mean well I
do yeah so I was just checking my
fantasy baseball yeah no that's
important dude yeah so why do you do
Fantasy Baseball uh well first of all I
love baseball there's okay there you go
but that's not the reason oh okay
because a lot of people love baseball
are like you play Fantasy what a loser
and I say I'm not a loser and then then
what happens and then I slap them with a
glove not with my hand glove yeah I
bring a glove now you take it off first
dude Robin Hood prince of Thieves
remember that was out for what that's
from no you can slap with a glove and
then he takes the armor glove and slaps
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I can't
believe I remember that and uh I I can't
believe I remember that to be honest so
I play Fantasy Baseball because I
remember more than you can't believe you
remember it it's like it brings me such
Joy now I don't want to dig deep on why
okay because it's going to start to piss
me off because I'm gonna get close to my
feelings in a way that I'm not
comfortable yet let me think about it
bring it back next week we'll talk more
about it about why you like to examine
oops you said it you didn't even get it
right the second time fantasy football
basket baseball well there there is
fantasy all of them yeah for sure yeah
yeah and I used to do all of them I'm
into fantasy tennis
that I bet it exists actually wow it's
just one person yeah but you can do it
like as a group I got people Sampras
yeah exactly yeah I mean so old you know
dude I got Jennifer Capriati oh my god
wow remember when Monica sellers got
stabbed on the court
no that was crazy I don't remember that
movie was the coolest she would go oh
yeah yeah you hit the ball you know yep
dude if I was a tennis player uh-oh oh
my God I wish sometimes I this is why
I'm a comedian but I wish I was
I I wish I was something else sometimes
so I could do it the funniest way
but you would be so bad no one would
that's the catch allow you into
tournament I know well no if I was a
if I was as good of a tennis player as
ever I am comedian yeah I'd be right
well sure yeah okay so I would be I
would be the guy who would go oh no and
I do it okay
uh oh that would be so dope yeah you
would get famous because players that
are like a little bit more bombastic and
look at me than others definitely don't
have don't have to be as good yeah if
they're like because look watchable I
wouldn't be the number one tennis player
I would be whatever number I am comedian
but I would be like oh no oh that's not
that entertaining just oh it is are you
kidding me I don't think oops ah [__]
actually I can't say wow [__] you know
Upsy Daisy let's see you handle that one
that'd be me yelling so loud but that
but well you'd have to be because so
everyone in Wimbledon could hear it is
it hard to mix these episodes because
Chris is yelling so much
no that's the thing maybe I make it
shorter yeah that's why it's that's why
the players that do do that are just
like because it's quick yeah and it's
cinchy wow because you know what that
means it's cinch simple yeah yeah simple
all in the days work dude I would be you
know how many endorsement deals I'd have
you probably people probably think
you're absolutely crazy but that's okay
but then I would sit and I would do
regular interviews like uh and then
behind the what do they call it post
game [__] and I would just be like yeah
no it's just you know that's how I do it
I'm you know I I gotta do it because
that's that's it man you know and people
be like all right well he's not crazy
it's a cinch it's a cinch and then that
would be a shirt dude I'm the man
there's a guy like that right now all
right yeah who is that guy I was just
thinking about that who is that guy Nick
curios and what does he do he's very
bombastic loud does funny things during
the thing and where's he from again and
he's from uh Australia right yeah yeah
yeah of Greek descent I think yeah yeah
he's like kind of cool looking too right
yeah he's cool yeah like to see him try
to stand up but anyway but exactly to
your point he's he hasn't won a whole
lot of like he's really good yeah of
course right but um yeah he hasn't been
winning but he's so everybody wants to
watch it there you go people don't do
that because they think the game is pure
hey this is what I say to that hey dude
hitting the ball around there's a huge
argument in most sports but right now in
baseball because it's kind of still the
most old-fashioned in a way right uh
yeah true American Sports yeah uh
but like the bat flips and the Really
exuberant celebrations old school
players are like that's not how you play
the game it's like do you want people to
watch it fans to just go away yeah it's
crazy you want to get new fins because
new fans will come when players are
going crazy and doing funny interesting
stuff yep not just hitting a home run to
win the game they just like Trotter on
the bases and then go home
you gotta do a cool back flip you gotta
like do something to the fans whether
you're at home you like pump them up
you're away you give them the bird
whatever you know yep yeah dude you
can't even see Charlie on my lap right
now but her entire fat hot body is on my
you can see her
you can see oh there's oh her butt dude
that's hilarious only her butt is
protruding I can see her whole back
you're wrong oh you're blind so oh no
that's just a butt that's just her butt
all right well so you're pissed me off
so now I can see her yeah because you're
behind the table okay no I can see it on
the screen is what I'm saying yes yeah
that's the guy I was thinking of yeah
well really the guy that you mentioned
what do you mean that's the guy you were
thinking of you said the guy and he
Googled the guy no he said the guy and I
I said I think I know that oh nice nice
nice nice all right so um so that's cool
if I was a tennis player that's how I
would be okay now that we've established
that should we get going okay I you know
I got most improved when I was in when I
was 12 years old doing playing tennis
Mrs you were so bad you had a big way to
go I was so so bad but I got most
improved legit I didn't get most
improved like is it wasn't Mysteries
right yeah yeah I got most improved
because it was legit dude I was a I was
a real uh I was a really good tennis
player as a kid remember they'd give
everybody Mr hustle oh dude yeah they
suck nobody wanted it if you got Mr
hustle everyone would tease you I got it
once in basketball but it's just like
foreign
highest scorer greatest player
most rebounds and seven Mr hustles dude
you know what I have all the Asian kids
and [__] and me I hold a record at our
high school that we both went to
basketball record not even a baseball
record but basketball I took
the most three-pointers ever in a season
and also missed by far the most
three-pointers ever taken that's a
horrible record isn't that crazy is it
up in like the locker rooms well no one
would ever they don't put the
shamefulness but I wish they I wish it
was yeah that'd be amazing but yeah I
shot like 7c 73 77 threes that's too
many and made 11. oh my God so all right
well look if you you like the banter
going over to Lifeline luxury
patreon.com
uh we dropped that start dropping the
episodes uh June uh fourth so uh let's
get into the show though huh let's get
into the show Lifeline the OG Lifeline
let's get into it let's see what you got
here
Harlequin hey guys uh my name is Alyssa
I live in Florida and I'm 25 years old
my hair is so good um I work in window
tinting
it is yeah nice
as you can see
um and
because I'm a girl I get guys that come
into my store that talk to me like I'm a
[__] idiot or they just try to bypass
me and go straight to my boss
um a lot of times I get guys that just
don't want to deal with me at all
um so I'm looking for some spin moves
um because I don't really know how to
handle these situations until after
people have already left
um so I because then like you know your
brain starts going into [__] that you
could have said that you didn't
um so I'm just looking for some stuff to
keep in the Arsenal to hit them with you
know
anything would be appreciated I love you
so much Chrissy we're awesome in
Lakeland thank you for [__] coming to
Lakeland yeah um and I'll see you in
Fort Myers hell yeah dude oh cool I love
uh yeah that's actually the Lakeland
show is
so fun um off the chain I was gonna say
it was fire no don't ever say that well
because I'm 43 no just because no if it
doesn't think it's oh it's fine every
time somebody says that's fire I think
dumb okay why didn't say it no I know
that's why I said good but even if I did
say I think it's down for different
reasons about you okay
um
um so I'm very rude that's that's hard
because to me obviously I'm wrong but to
me even
even shitty chauvinistic men wouldn't be
like that about window tinting in my
mind but like yeah obviously I'm wrong
yeah and that doesn't that doesn't like
shock me but it's still kind of like
that seems weird because it's you're not
better or worse at
really like window tinting is not
doesn't require anything particularly
unique it's a skill that you learn but
it's not particularly uniquely male in
any way oh got it and yeah so that those
guys because it's a car thing guys think
it's a car thing maybe which which is
stupid but yeah it is stupid yeah but
but it's like like the whole muscle car
tinted kind of I don't know I I guess I
guess the thing would be something about
that but you don't want to go and get
fired dude so like you don't want to
come at them too hard because you're
gonna potentially lose a customer and
then your boss is gonna get mad so you
got to kind of be like maybe passive
aggressive about it in a in a funny way
yeah but like just taking the task in a
way that's like kind of like not cutting
off his balls but putting them in a vice
yeah
you want to see my manager wait by the
way she's would they ask for the boss or
what her boss her boss you want to see
my boss just because I don't have a
penis
okay
I mean that might be good or here's what
I really think you should do honestly
this is what you really should do
um talk to your boss about it oh that's
good and say Hey listen this happens a
lot
that's good can you have my back yeah
back me up when this happens yeah right
because then the boss comes out and says
hey what's going on and they say well I
wanted to do this and that and she said
well what's wrong with her handling it
she can handle it right
and you told me that I would love to do
that right yeah that's the move if
you're even if you're if I would say if
you're tight with your boss cool even if
you're not it's cool because like dude
that's so annoying you know and your
boss will agree your boss hired you yeah
so like unless he's a piece of [__] and
if he's a piece of [__] then you got a
whole nother issue there but but it's
right I would I would imagine he's not a
piece of [__] in that regard all other
piece of shitness is on the table but I
I would venture to guess he's not sexist
because he hired you right true so uh I
would imagine he would be receptive to
that uh
in in the first place so that's a good
idea yeah you almost never have the
right pretty much have the most fire
ideas wow and that idea was super fire
that was good all right okay good cool
there we go
hey Chris you know what what uh Wellness
is more than just about nutrition and
exercise it's all it's about it's
physical it's mental and emotional okay
so sleep so you're saying so sleep
Stress Management and mindfulness are
all important aspects of Wellness right
and this is why next Evo CBD products
are where it's at do your research
before you buy means making better
informed choices especially when it
comes to stress or Sleep Products like
CBD did you know that a study by an
independent lab confirms some Brands
contain up to 60 less CBD than they
claim to on the label but with next Evo
Naturals you can trust you're getting
the best of the best as the most
clinically studied CBD brand on the
market do you understand that next Evo
the most wow the most clinically studied
CBD brand on the market uh next Evo
takes research to the next level great
to relieve stress great to pop and then
get in bed and have a great night's
sleep I know that you've done that uh
wake up feeling what refreshed and well
rested which is rare enough doing 100
your own stuff using this is great vegan
GMO free gluten-free THC free capsules
and gummies derived from 100 U.S grown
hemp upgrade your CBD go to nextevo.com
Lifeline to get 20 off your first order
of 40 or more that's 20 off 40 or more
at
n-e-x-t-e-v-o.com slash lifeline
nice hoodie started over obviously
because we're talking and started over
and there we go they've got a condom for
a hat and the hoodie handsome
me I am no him okay what's going on guys
I just want to start by saying that I
love you guys relationship as brothers
my brother wasn't around too much
growing up so I get to live vicariously
through you guys and [__] rules
that's cool um my wife takes too many
pictures wow uh we go on a walk she
takes 50 pictures that's hilarious she's
editing the pictures while we're walking
you know
uh we go to a restaurant we do whatever
she's taking a million pictures and I'm
not really I don't like taking pictures
I never have I'm not really a smiley
kind of guy
um I mean I smile of course but like
when it comes to pictures I just never
feel like taking it it's not good yeah
I'm a very in the moment just be there
and remember it later I don't need a
picture for it uh am I being a dick let
me know uh Chris been a fan since
Midwest City Oklahoma years ago Matt
your style is impeccable I remember that
I [__] love you guys I'm glad I
called him handsome at the top because
he complimented me at the end what do
you think he is out of ten an eight oh I
would say between eight and a half yeah
okay because um do you know what I am
yeah like I said six and a half that's
seven you're like a seven that is
no that's a low-key crazy I'm fire you
you should agree with that seven seven
is good it's not it's okay bro but when
you it's not a d you know what I'm
saying yeah it's a c yeah
exactly it's not a d so listen uh I
don't think you're a dick I I have a
whole thing where look I'm much
happier these days like when I'm with my
family
and [__] and we're taking pictures I
actually feel happy so I'll smile but I
used to be on that [__] where it's like
dude I'm not gonna smile unless I'm
happy you want to remember the time the
way it was you don't want to look back
on these pictures and you're just in
every picture like this
this guy was just always happy well
that's why I don't I don't like post
right post pictures yeah that's why if
if she's just taking pictures I was
gonna say this actually but continue
when I'm done when you're just taking
pictures of what's going on yeah it
doesn't bother me when you're like
needing to stop the moments yeah that's
pose horrific that's uh every it ruins
everything and like yeah maybe just wait
to the end ask her to like
wait till something's nearing an end to
like get all the photos that we're all
going to get together yeah or get them
out of the way in the beginning don't
like do it throughout uh also the
editing while you're after yeah after
you've taken them while you're out still
you gotta She's Gotta compromise no
photo editing until she gets home a
photo edit when you're at home yeah
doing your own thing yeah that's not a
group activity or a couple of activity
then she's literally being anti-social
yeah taking photos is still a social
thing to do making people pose for a
photo more than like once I get it if
you want to do it once that's fine but
that's like you're basically that's a
smaller version of the guy at the party
with who wants to play a guitar you're
like oh no not bad dude it's a smaller
version I said yeah but you shouldn't
it's not even the same bulb it's not
even the same I was gonna say ballpark
it's not in the same ball game yeah but
it's a it's a smaller version because
you have to stop what you're doing and
do that then much more you shouldn't say
much if you said much okay because I
didn't say the word much you're gonna
get on me for that I am that's crazy bro
I am and
all the calamari dude you know what's
weird is it's really uh nice that people
say they do say that they live
vicariously through us as brothers like
that and what is that I know what
vicarious means oh I know for sure but
like they didn't have their relationship
with their brother like that well what
they're saying is that they have a
sibling
I think you know women say it too about
theirs yeah yeah and brothers yeah uh it
reminds them of them no it it they
weren't close as he said they weren't
that close with their sibling growing up
and they always wished they were not
like one really wanted to be all the
time with the sibling and the other one
didn't yeah it's just like that
closeness isn't initially there yeah and
they wish that they were naturally
closer with their siblings my sense of
what they're talking about uh which
I actually have evolving thoughts on
this like I
I know what people mean when they say
that but what I've realized as I've gone
on in years is like
most people straight up most buy good
amount don't have a good relationship
not just with their siblings but with
their families in general like they they
don't like want to see them over the
holidays they don't really want to call
them to check in it's like
so and I obviously get it but like this
I find that very interesting and
unfortunate because there's a lot of
people like that who really do wish they
uh had that like natural inkling to want
to be close
it's like they don't hate their siblings
it's not like they butt heads but it's
like they don't have that thing you know
yeah I really hope that uh I mean we're
really close with our family and all
that stuff and obviously we're close
um William and Calvin Calvin William I
just think it I really like I'm so happy
that they have each other and I can't
wait for them to have that man like like
William is at the point where he just
started to open his eyes and stuff and
like look around and like smile a little
bit and it's just like today Calvin came
into the room this morning any any and
um and I you know he was like
and why was he doing that because he
just in the morning he just does kind of
sometimes you know how do you kind of
yeah like he's just saying I'm going
downstairs and um you come you come and
look at [__] and stuff no no because
he's no I'm just Jack the man yeah of
the house and so I uh so so Kristen was
with William already was like six
something feeding him and I was like
come on buddy let's go to your room and
I went into his room and his
bed and we slept together for another
few hours and I I just think it's like
it to think that like I get to do that
again with William after Calvin gets too
old and like I'm gonna be with both of
them and they're both gonna have each
other as
it's the most
beautiful thing dude and I I really wish
that people could like have that you
know and not everybody does I guess and
um you know we're lucky to have that at
the same time I think being an only
child would be pretty sick people are
always like I don't think that would be
good I don't know why that like if
that's all you know and your parents are
cool yeah I mean being a silly child is
fine getting it all I'm getting it all
dude what I'm saying is being close with
your sibling versus not being of course
yeah I'm just yeah I'm taking it
somewhere else which is what people do
in conversations which is what this is
which is all good uh
all right yeah just tell her you can't
be anti-social take pictures yeah you
can't be anti-social and that almost
kind of does include taking too many
posed photos because you're breaking up
yeah social Gathering and and ruining it
once everyone's laughing so hard with
three people like so hard like we were
having a ball it was on a plane and then
one of the people said you guys want to
play a game and it ruined everything you
hate games uh yeah but ruined everything
we were laughing crying laughing and
she's like you want to play a game and
we go oh and she was to explain some
game neither of us knew and it was like
that okay we'll try and it was so bad
dude
that's yeah play a game while you're
having the best time that's odd yup dude
what's better
yeah
anyway you want to play Candyland
while we're recording what's better than
what's better having sex or having a
time where you're just laughing so hard
with everyone
well because the latter is much much
much more specific and guarantees you're
having an insanely good time definitely
that yeah I agree so uh that would be
worse than in the middle of sex being
like yo let's stop and have a and play a
game
there you go well that the ladder was
figured it out so weird the first one's
weird the first ladder would be demented
dude equally as weird just like having
sex with your girlfriend you know yeah
and then all of a sudden your
girlfriend's like I'll have the calamari
all right let's do it uh I'll have a
culinary one on having sex with my
girlfriend you know disgusting let's do
it absolutely disgusting hey guys what
up it's your boy it's your Army in the
back with the sweet mate that goes
oh yeah what do you say first of all I'm
he's the guy in this video he's the guy
who has the roommate that's always
Hawking oh
oh oh I remember this guy all right dude
from the beginning again I want to hear
it
got airpods suck huh
they do hey guys what up it's your boy
in the Army in the barracks with the
sweet mate that goes
um first of all I'm absolutely pissed
that I'm wearing a v-neck in this video
but it's okay besides the point I took
your advice and I confronted yeah
it is helpful in person and I'm like hey
you shot him uh clean the bathroom
please and he goes all right I'm like
okay that's good so I give him a few
days right okay guess if he does it no
of course not so
I that's actually weird then I type up a
note and I print it
and I slide it under his door okay
uh and I give him a few days then I run
into them in person again whoa and he
says hey I got your letter and I'm like
okay and he's like
uh I bought a bunch of stuff to clean
the bathroom and I'm like okay
okay
if I can do it right yeah and he doesn't
do it still didn't do it okay now what
do I do like like I know that I can
reach out to his commander and be like
yeah he is dirty this guy's dirty you
know blah blah I don't know get him in
trouble but like I also don't want to be
a rat but oh God I don't know what to do
anymore it's all right if it's windy but
[__] okay
ours is a really good submission man I
like that guy's attitude I like him too
my favorite guy I've ever known in the
Army you're my Army buddy and I love you
I was in the Army but okay ah really so
actually no he was mom was in the Army
okay so my second favorite Grand Army my
mom is in the Army she was like during
the band guys
[Laughter]
on yeah
all right uh I mean dude just you've
gone far enough just go all the way and
be like use the supplies you bought man
are you trolling me because at this
point it's like he's just like pulling
your leg like like you okay dude hey you
said you bought the stuff use it yeah
like everyone does with things they buy
yeah man I don't really know how I feel
about this because you you taught him
you taught him twice now
and he's on his way to do it he hasn't
done it yet he says he's got the stuff
so great
I don't believe in being a rat yeah no
but also if it's not getting done then
what is the what what you got to do what
I said you got to say hey yeah we this
is the third time right right you went
so far as to buy supplies which I
appreciate yeah now I'm just like you're
not using them and to to comply with my
request which you said you were going to
do you need to use the things you bought
yeah because they don't magically use
themselves yeah there you go that's a
good thing to say don't say comply but
yeah yeah I mean especially the guy in
the Army yeah that's why I said that I
messed up but uh yeah men don't like to
be told they have to comply but like he
met if you put it in the context of I
made a request and you said okay like I
compliance or you could just literally
just walk up to him and be like hey
comply right yeah and then hand them the
liquid 409 or whatever you have you know
yeah
all right cool wow or or look at his
supplies like say it's liquid 409 or
Windex or whatever and go into his room
and like look at it and just be like and
like be examining it until he says like
what are you doing and you're like oh
it's weird it doesn't look like this was
yeah the seal is still on yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so it hasn't even been used to
be like
yeah this doesn't these don't you
use it themselves yeah right yeah what
the heck do you bottle these supplies
and they don't even use it themselves
what the heck is going on it's almost
like somebody needs to use these for the
bathroom
wow you woke up Charlie good job it's
okay all right uh yeah next one
cool hey Chris man how do I get this
baby
um I had two things I wanted to say it
looks cool the first of which is I think
a good entry-level horror movie look how
cute uh Papa Duke oh yeah okay it's good
it has that high tension yeah babadook
is good and that baby is so cute it has
really good allegory yeah you're right
you're right so that creates a nice
competition with people I'm pissed but
he's right because I didn't think of it
scary enough before I think it'll sort
of get into your head
um but not too scary to scare people
away from the genre yeah yeah that's a
good call stop showing me up though that
was uh my input on the topic
um
the second thing uh is about this little
guy um so I just that's a cute kid I
want to avoid him having any food
aversions in the future my uh nephew he
has so many food aversions he'll only
eat like three different foods that's so
common
um
this guy will eat anything right now but
hey including his finger eight months
old so I'm worried about in the future
if he will uh hate everything like my
nephew I'm wondering if any of you guys
have any uh advice on the topic uh not
workers
because I really want him to have a
diverse palette yeah enjoy the delicious
foods that we enjoy spicy food and all
that give them the spicy stuff I'm
rambling I love you guys
um hope this finds you well and I hope
you're very soon yeah
um the that's a real thing but if
honestly if he's eight months and
already eating everything then it's
you're probably safe really
um was it really yeah like
if you're eight months and he's already
eating a lot of stuff that's great like
Calvin wasn't
um Calvin wasn't and you're saying even
at eight months he was picky he yeah he
really yeah yeah for sure well and he's
kind of picky he's picky now no I know
that now
you know it's really good and
advantageous to give them everything
early on like everything like even like
raw fish and just
I mean everything they they they
might not like it but they will develop
a taste for having a wider range of food
that they like and my son has a fine
okay range it's not great but um we made
sure to at least make him kind of get
him to try I should say make him but get
him to try a lot of the things
um and even spicy stuff he likes Sushi
um yeah he does and so but a lot of
times now if it looks weird he'll be
like I don't like that and I was like
I'm like buddy
you don't know if you don't like it yet
can you at least try it because this
thing happened where we would use this
toothpaste and then I'd switch the
toothpaste and he was like no I don't
like it and I was like buddy you didn't
even try it and we spent like 10 minutes
in his defense even if a new toothpaste
is good and I will eventually like it
the first time I use it it makes me want
to throw up something about new
toothpaste weird well I'm so bad to me
okay uh so I don't like it Eva yeah
um so British so I said to him I was
like buddy try it it took like 10
minutes I was like please just at least
try it I give him a little bit and he
goes like this he goes and he's he
literally goes like this
I like it so now I mean it was so funny
and then so now what I do is do you
remember the toothpaste remember you
didn't like it and now and then you
liked it this is going to be like that
most likely so maybe try it if you don't
like it then you don't have to eat it
any and then he now he's coming around
to being like okay and he'll go like you
know and normally he likes it because
it's good food we order good food it
makes good food and um
but sometimes he's just like no I don't
like it and then we just say all right
well then you don't have to eat it but
it's you know it earlier on is the best
way to do it and if you're doing it at
eight months and he'll eat anything then
I would venture to say it's probably
gonna be okay I would say that it was
his nephew they probably didn't expose
him to many things also I could be wrong
with this but I feel like I've heard
that
it actually lessens the likelihood of
there being stomach problems or even
maybe allergies later in life because
it's like an antibiotics yeah if they're
antibiotics antibodies like you get them
if you're slightly exposed to [__] there
was a study that something like it's
like an Israel or something where
the the food
um there was a like I think it was a
peanut allergy that was like very uh uh
prevalent
and they realized it's because they they
thought that back way back whenever
um
peanuts were bad for children dude
that's specifically what I had heard
what I just said about peanuts they were
like exposed chosen to peanuts I don't
know yeah I didn't read that study yeah
but I had heard that and and then it
went away when they started realizing oh
they're not bad for kids and then now
there's way less of a peanut allergy
stuff his face with peanuts that's my
advice okay well it is kind of weird
though if you do have a peanut allergy
you just kind of got to like wait it out
you give it to a baby you're like I hope
this is okay
right but I think the point is
the point is that it's likely to lead to
them not having an allergy right yes it
is yeah yeah
okay okay next one
um we're doctors yeah hey Chris and Matt
I love you guys this is Sandy I have a
dating question I was wondering how long
it takes men to get over a serious
relationship I met a guy about three
weeks ago and we had a really great
connection we were getting ready to
introduce our kids and then he got
scared and said that he wasn't ready we
both were in a relationship that was
toxic and they lasted about three to
four years so I'm not gonna wait around
for this guy but I'm also wondering
when or what to do if he does come back
um yeah and Chris you were great in
Cincinnati I love you thanks cute
Cincinnati was [__] awesome
uh uh okay
first of all I think the answer to your
just general question about how long
does it take for guys to get over a
partner I don't I don't maybe I'm wrong
but I don't think it's
time-wise I don't think it's different
for women and men but I think the men
that or at least personally in my
experience I should say uh I the the
amount of time it takes for me to get
over somebody is pretty much not always
but pretty much directly correlated to
how soon I meet someone that yeah sort
of like takes that person's face in my
brain not fully not and not certainly
not the same way but the same amount of
interest and Amorous feelings towards
them like it tends to be either a long
time that I can long from my previous
relationship because it was I haven't
found a new one and it's like yeah fair
you think about what went wrong yeah
what you might have been able to do
differently but until you know once I
would meet someone new it was like it
was almost like to visualize it just
like completely like one person exits my
brain and the other one is new and then
it's like voila as they say I do think
that it's bad that
um
I do think that it's not the best to do
that though I think it's best to get
over something for sure but yeah I
definitely have done that I'm almost
exclusively I mean it's it's so hard the
reason I say that though is because
kind of a litmus test if the guy is into
you because like it wouldn't matter how
long it's been if he's really into you
then like yeah his mind wouldn't still
be clogged yeah right unless he's got
like PTSD or something like that from a
previously that's different that's a
whole different that's different if it's
not that I would agree He's Just Not
That Into You yeah but if it's just
about you know that relationship ended
and it's all good and whatever everybody
just moved on
and yet he's still thinking about his ex
or you know still Trip has trepidation
about with you because whatever it's
probably
I never want to say definitely but it's
probably a sign that he is still hung up
on the previous girl yeah yeah or uh
I don't know maybe it's like a I'm
trying to think of well I I shouldn't
[__] throw this out there but I don't
know maybe he doesn't want his kids to
meet you because then the kids will say
some to the mom or something you know
that's always true I don't know I
shouldn't but would he let the
relationship end if that was right yeah
I don't know maybe it's not too serious
it comes back it's if you're saying that
it makes me think you have a reason to
believe that so if he does come back in
one way or another or Circle back around
somehow whatever uh I think that you
should just put it to him like that
you should just say hey look I totally
get it everybody has different
experiences with different people and
sometimes it's longer to heal than other
people but like if you are seriously
interested in me then it shouldn't be a
problem about your act like it's just
not yeah yeah I say that you know yeah
if if he comes nicely say it say it it's
like totally straightforward and warm as
as you can because it's it's it's just
true and you don't have to hold hard
feelings against him for that but like
you know you should put it into his head
that that is your your feeling those are
your feelings okay cool yeah that's a
good idea I'm sorry I wasn't funnier but
that's the truth well I'm just saying do
some funny right now and then we're
going on okay um so what do you guys um
well so no it's all good but um
alrighty so what's up with well all
right sweating oh here we go we get a
phone call hey guys
just want to say thanks for doing what
you're doing very enjoyable I appreciate
it and uh I love you guys so my question
is
I'm seeing two females oops at the
moment one is someone who likes to do
the horizontal slam
multiple times a week and it's great
but we don't connect much on a
personal level yeah
whereas the other one we connect great
on a personal level have very good
conversations nice guy but
the horizontal slamming is limited to
once a week or once every couple weeks
so
just in your opinion what should I do
um
and in the past I went with the one that
loved to do the slamming and she cheated
on me so wow yeah any advice would be
great
all right I actually have a specific
thing to say about house so let me go
first okay
first of all if you're doing that I'm
not I'm not moralizing but like you
should probably be in the open about it
to some degree or another that they both
know you're not exclusive with them
that's it but beyond that I would say if
you actually need to make a choice and
they because like they don't know that
you're seeing both of them or if one of
them put it to you I know you're seeing
other people but I want to be whatever
I would say that if you actually need to
make a choice you should choose the one
that you have the greater emotional
connection with and it's not necessarily
for an obvious reason I think the reason
really is
I know so myself included I know so many
people who have had
somewhere around two-year relationships
many times throughout the course of
their life then that relationship ends
and the reason that happens I this is a
thing I learned and I'm full of things I
learned because I'm smart Okay so one of
the things I've learned was that
typically that's around the time that
the like
love and lust chemicals eggs wear off
and the high of meeting someone new and
have being super like uh physical with
them and being horizontal Ramen whatever
uh I know so it wasn't that I read that
once it was like 15 years ago uh those
chemicals tend to wear off and what
you're left with is just the person
across from you and how much you like
them and if you're two years in and you
know you're wondering like oh what's
going on something's wrong you know I'm
not really feeling the way you used to
that's very likely what's going on but
if it's someone you like a lot as a
human being and you connect really well
about other stuff Beyond just like lust
things then you probably will not run
into those you might run into other
issues but you won't run into that issue
so if you plan on being with someone
long term absolutely without a doubt I
would tell you to just go with the one
that you're emotion more emotionally
connected to yeah I mean look you're
saying that basically sex becomes the
same for everyone after five years
anyway and so you should be with someone
that you could have a conversation with
and that's how short and succinct you
can possibly say it but you took a long
way and that's fine but what I'm saying
people want to know the reason I know
but you well I guess yeah true but but
the guy is
um look you're having sex once a week or
once every two weeks me no his I'm just
kidding he he's obviously that's not
really that bad that's yeah but I I mean
right I agree but it depends on the
context like you see like please can we
just oh well definitely yeah but he
didn't say that so sure right and then
also uh is it good sex if it's good sex
and she just doesn't want to have it
that much
I still think that that's absolutely
okay and that's good especially if
you're going to live a life with this I
agree you know if if obviously the sex
is probably better with the woman that
he's having it a lot I mean I'm just
right I'm just guessing if he's having
it a lot she's into it I bet it was
probably it's probably it's probably
better but sex is very very important in
a relationship but it's also but super
individual and unique everyone's unique
some people have lower libidos it
doesn't have anything to do with you
yeah so there's no reason to personalize
it sometimes it does but generally you
get a sense of when that's the case yeah
plus squirting off the lifesaver
I'm sorry squirting off's a lifesaver by
yourself and your loan and you're alone
oh oh oh by your lovely squirting loves
but yeah squirting off is a is a
lifesaver definitely don't say Square
now okay but I'm just saying it's a
lifesaver actually in any context but
certainly though okay okay remember that
[__] can the co this uh soda squirt
of course it's bad oh it's really bad
and moving on
oh
to squirt
I don't really drink any sauce
Cactus Cooler worst there is nothing
worse people used to actually there was
a like a urban legend that they had wood
chips yep remember that yep I do
remember that so dumb that's how Groot
came became hold on yeah Cactus Cooler
wood chips at least sure it's gonna show
up something
yeah
Butthead the way you just said oh you
guys don't like Cactus Cooler no no but
you do a hundred percent yeah because
you like really bad stuff I haven't had
one in years but you loved it right when
I was a kid yeah there you go dude I
honestly don't think I'm from the guy
who likes terrifier oh look I'm sure
that's it why you should never drink
Cactus Cooler because it's out of wood
chips go ahead
the worst thank you I would never hear
something that was an emergency for me I
needed that to be off so bad
um anyway dude Cactus Cooler is terrible
uh the only thing cool back Cactus
Cooler is the design of the can yeah it
is and it's so bad and one time I saw a
guy uh drinking a Cactus Cooler in high
school when I was in high school and
um
he sparked a loogie in his Cactus Cooler
because he was done with it like he had
a little bit left but he was done with
it and some guy said uh hey what's up to
him and he goes hey man here you want
the rest of my Cactus Cooler and he took
it and drank it and walked away and
drank it and I felt so bad and I saw
that happen
I don't like that I don't like it either
and I know the two guys who did it and I
still know the two guys who did it and I
should tell him hey look at that I can
that's the best can dude it's different
now it is different and what's weird is
that they updated it and it's still good
that is usually when they updated can
it's terrible that's the new one yeah
that's good yeah that's that's terrible
it made it worse
if that one that's great the best the OG
Cactus Cooler oh wait my favorite cans
are the old look at that old one that's
nice the old Mr Pibb or the old RC Cola
those are my two favorites RC cola's
cool
but the new ones are ruined just like
the just like every other thing look at
now look at the new ones those are so
dope now look at how ugly that is yeah
it's terrible like calm
dude dropped it off he's like Diddy now
dude I um
I I was hanging out with the chick once
and she was really beautiful sorry is
that doctor you know I'm trying to say
syrup yeah it's obviously a joker left
Dr Pepper dessert topping disgusting no
that's real oh my God ew
sorry I interrupted you but that is dis
yeah but you could have could have held
it but Dr Pepper Cherry dude if you do
that if you use that you're absolutely
disgusting okay go ahead
hang out with a chick was beautiful like
this was years ago really beautiful and
she was like
and she said something she goes yeah man
it was [__] sick
and I go and I was like oh that's like
the worst thing to do should I introduce
it to me
I got the egg dude
we're on the couch together and she goes
yeah that's [__] suit and I go
and my penis goes
you know what's the the way to do it
though what when you're gonna do that
it's good to say it anyway but it's best
to say it when you go like this
I mean imagine she did it on the couch
yeah then she would have sleep yeah
exactly and dude and it was she was so
hot and
dude and Eddie Murphy and Boomerang who
what what you're doing why because like
that's not a reason to to not be
interested in someone anymore was that a
boom or anything yeah Boomerang who was
like the the biggest like player in
Washington DC and the very beginning of
the movie he's like with this extremely
ludicrously beautiful woman yeah and he
pulls the sheets up or she does yeah and
it reveals that she has like corn all
over her feet okay and he's just like
he's just like uh you know like Eddie
Murphy you know isn't Boomerang the
movie with uh
oh that's where he plays two people I
actually don't know I only saw him Rings
the one where he was like where he's
like a dorky with braces right no that's
uh uh uh uh Bowfinger uh okay okay her
finger's hilarious that's right okay so
yeah so wait so she also that lady who
did that the thing that said she was so
strong I remember
that's [__] see was it a guy but she
was so strong is his name Peter
yeah her name was Peter and she played
for the A's yeah I think that was a guy
uh all right
next one
Matt and Chris uh love you guys love
what you do my question is about uh baby
mamas my daughter's mom lives in
Massachusetts uh we've had a mostly
peaceful relationship over the last five
years it's good oh I met someone last
year and uh ever since then it's been
negativity and putting thoughts into my
daughter's head about a replacement
mommy nothing could be
stuff honestly I'm getting tired and uh
dizzy from all the spin moves uh just
give me some advice man uh Chris come to
South Florida I'd love to see you I love
you guys later
I wanna I'm working on trying to get to
follow you got it
um one of my favorite places to perform
but um I don't even know what to say to
this guy I can only get really vague
generic advice yeah
uh that's rough bro I guess the only
thing you can do is sometimes the people
that do [__] like that it's like you
even trying to broach the subject with
them makes it worse because then they
know you're now you're noticing it and
it's getting under your skin and like
they're only remaining way to be present
in your mind is to at least be under
your skin and that's a really bad place
to be with someone uh so I would suggest
if that's the kind of person you're
dealing with
you might have just honestly just talked
to your daughter and like
not even acknowledge it with with
because he says he's tried stuff before
and if it's not happening like you I
don't know how old your daughter is but
over five
that's what he said well he said that
he's been oh not with the mom for five
years so that would be so weird if he
said you know my daughter she's over
five uh
uh yeah yeah I I don't know though like
I don't know anything about your ex-wife
and or your daughter for that matter but
I I I feel like that sounds like the
kind of person that might take the the
just the fact that you're noticing and
getting upset that might make her take
it up a notch yeah when you dicey this
is dicey when you yeah when you react to
somebody then it means that they got
what they wanted sometimes so I don't
know man I I just um
this is a tough thing man this is why
it's hard right this is why this kind of
shit's hard is like when you know
divorce and all that stuff or baby mama
I don't know you were married but
um
I guess you should you know
yeah maybe have a a delicate
conversation with your daughter though
because like of course like the worst
thing to do and this is the worst and
and this is the worst and no matter what
happens with you and your Lo and your
baby mom baby dad whatever it is never
[__] talk [__] yeah to the uh to
about the other person to your child
that's horrible yeah that's the worst
that's the worst thing you can do to the
child so you know I can't control what
she says but you can't control what you
said
um and so just don't do that but you can
have a very delicate conversation with
your daughter I think but I just you
know it's it's a it's a rough thing dude
I'm sorry you're going through it just
talk to your daughter about like this is
not a replacement mommy situation this
is a totally separate thing you'll never
have a different relationship with your
mom and I would never want you to anyway
but that's what the mom is saying she's
having a problem with like I don't want
this to be a replacement Mom right no I
what I gather I don't know okay but what
I gathered was
when the mom is with the daughter and
she's like
talking about how her daddy wants a
replacement mom is trying to do that yes
then yeah you have to have the
conversation with your daughter yeah
yeah got it yeah that's rough bro Jesus
man that's sad yeah sucks for your
daughter so much I know
uh okay uh okay from New Jersey doctor
my name is Jordan I am a photographer
a novice photographer I've just been the
last couple months
um really loving it taking pictures cool
and uh the only thing I have a little
trouble with is people because people
make the best subjects and sometimes
somebody has a really unique look and I
want to ask them to take their picture
for my portfolio and just do build
experience
um but I'm a little hesitant because I
think it can probably come off as creepy
like if I just total stranger go up to
somebody who has to take their picture
that face um so I'm just wondering if
you guys have any advice
to ask total strangers if I can take
their picture in the least creepy way
possible
um by the way my stuff is on Instagram
jofo underscore Hollywood okay
j-o-f-o underscore Hollywood all right
let's check it out all my photos thanks
guys you're the best
once until now has someone plugged them
so yeah that's actually crazy yeah yeah
um and when you call in don't do that
but but we'll look at it but but so he
uh
is a photographer is this what you do
I'm going to judge your stuff right now
though bro but okay tell them what to do
this is what you do you walk up to the
people with your Instagram you say this
is my stuff I'm a photographer or just
pictures you've taken this is the stuff
I do I'd love to shoot you oh that's a
good idea so this way it's not it
doesn't seem creepy it's you know I also
think well he treats the hell out of him
dude uh I mean same thing twice same
thing three times
so
I mean those are definitely wild damn uh
sagrani what I would say also to Granny
that's great but to be clear to be like
if you want yeah a little bit more to
say you could say like uh before you say
anything you could be like look
obviously feel free to say no but right
yeah right yeah that's good go go to
some of them feel free to say no right
but like
um a Game Boy dude go back a Game Boy
took a picture of the game boy said
novice dude that looks so much like a
Game Boy it is it's the best it's the
phone case
wow yeah I'm such an old guy well that's
of nothing
so look keep going
uh that's cute so that's the best
picture you took yeah and it's the
people just like you said Yep they're
gonna take pictures of people's faces
yeah just walk up to them show them this
don't show them that one show them this
and just be like look I take pictures
this is stuff I do can I shoot you yeah
that's it I think that's the least
creepy thing I do think with this that's
a good picture that is a good picture I
do think that with the grainy stuff it
is a little bit creepy show I'm showing
the less green granny stuff show them
stuff with there we go there we go
someone's facing it period yeah there we
go not that one your face counts I guess
but no it does a selfie that is indeed a
selfie yeah yeah dude look you got
something there you go there you go
there you go show them that one
everybody wants to look cool that the
person looks cool that's a good one
that's a good one too that's cool dude
that's great honestly the ones with the
people are the ones that are good of
course so so says he knows that no I
know right I know that so so show them
that and and walk around with pictures
and be like this is the stuff I want to
say yeah this is the stuff I want to do
do you mind if I shoot your picture yeah
say yes great do it I think you'd make a
great subject be complimentary of them
without being like a weirdo person uh
and yeah and then if they say no scream
out your loss and run away and yeah
something like that I think it's great
good job you keep going though running
with those gear and his game boy
um I think yeah that's cool I'm glad
you're having a good time doing that man
people need to find you know you don't
need to find your passion you don't like
like we talked about this a long time
ago I think maybe you said it on the
solo episode you were talking about you
don't need a passion oh yes I agree yeah
um because I watch this episode because
I'm a good person I'm a good brother
um but uh yeah you don't need to find
your passion but if you did that's great
and right now it's a hobby and that's
cool but it you know you never know when
a hobby turns out to be an actual thing
you build your portfolio and that's it
it's on and popping dude do exactly what
I said do exactly what I said about the
thing I also be good for you one last
thing about you Jordan I think that
there was something early on in what you
were saying that and I really appreciate
it and I think more people should take
take note of this he said I'm a
photographer
without caveat then he continued to
explain more but it wasn't a caveat it
was just more of a description yeah yeah
I said I'm a novice yeah because you
just started
that is a good attitude he yeah it is a
good attitude wants to be a photographer
and the only way to be a photographer at
the beginning is to say you are one and
take pictures it's affirming yeah you
have to just believe it's like you know
all the time in LA I hear people that
are like you know I'm
trying to be a writer yeah it's like no
don't do it you are a writer or a writer
you know uh you don't have to get paid a
hundred grand per script to be actually
called a writer it's like a [__] bar
you made up you know that's why that's
why I walk around and say I'm a singer I
sing all the time and it doesn't matter
I don't get paid for it in a way I do
because I sing almost every podcast
[Music]
of us releasing Lifeline luxury
patreon.com luxury we drop June 4th
um two episodes a month or uh uh over 30
minutes at least two episodes a month uh
I am on tour christilia.com if you have
a question go to watch lifeline.com or
call 213-973-8095
you want one but one-on-one advice with
your boy that would be me go to
matalia.com and get the help you need
and lifelimage.com is we're all a hot
merch is you get that purple purple and
uh yeah and also leave a comment dude
that really helps us leave a comment for
the algorithm share it with your friends
try to get people involved in the show
we love you man thank you very much guys
[Music]